[Music]
before we start this video I just wanted
to mention that eighty seven point six
percent of you who watch this channel
aren't yet subscribed so if you enjoy
the content please hit the subscribe
button hey guys welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
once again Lord Voldemort you may also
know him as the Dark Lord
he-who-must-not-be-named
the heir of Slytherin or you-know-who
Voldemort is the perfect antagonist for
the Harry Potter films and his character
is the manifestation of all that is
wrong in the world a dark and twisted
man not sure he could still say that
after all of dark magic he's done that
wants nothing but power he is devoid of
emotion unable to feel empathy for
anyone even his closest companions and
will stop at nothing and his rise to
power over the course of the books and
films we see world mort's character
development to grow and grow and where
he starts off as just a name he slowly
becomes the dark and evil wizard played
by Ralph Fiennes that we see on screen
after a devastating loss to the Potters
modern Walt found himself without a
physical form and over the course of the
earlier films finds himself piecing his
body back together but what a lot of
people don't know or simply haven't
noticed is that Voldemort wasn't always
portrayed by Ralph Fiennes in the films
in fact Fiennes wasn't in the film
adaptations of Harry Potter at all until
the Goblet of Fire four years after the
first film came out this poses the
question who played Voldemort before him
Voldemort was in the films before then
wasn't he Voldemort's character is so
important in casting for him must have
been supremely difficult they would need
to effectively portray as sociopathic
tendencies with an element of charm we
first see Voldemort in the Philosopher's
Stone
we're brought back to the year 1981
where a cloaked figure is entering the
gate of the Potter residence in Godric's
Hollow then later on in the same film
was shown a horrible cloaked figure
feasting on eunuch
blood in the Forbidden Forest and
finally towards the end of the film we
see a face a face that just so happened
to be on the back professor quirrel head
Harry Potter we meet again he uttered as
Quirrell unravels his turban this face
of course belongs to the very first of
all Mort Richard Bremer Bremer was
responsible for acting out beginning
scene at Godric's Hollow as well as
obviously the scene where his face was
exposed Bremer is a British actor from
Warwickshire England and had a long
acting resume before taking on the role
of ultimate while Bremer did an amazing
job with his limited exposure in the
role he was eventually replaced by actor
Ralph Fiennes
even though Bremen did a great job when
the time came for Voldemort to make a
resurgence in the Goblet of Fire Warner
Brothers opted for a more famous actor
Fiennes who replaced Bremer was widely
recognized at this time and had an Oscar
nomination under his belt Harry Potter
had grown a lot since Bremen played the
role and had just made sense Bremer was
an exceptionally good sport about being
replaced and had this to say the
producer spent a long time fighting to
get me so I'm very proud to have been
the first but the role is now being
played by Ralph Fiennes who is an old
mate in the fourth film I've been in the
business a long time and it didn't
surprise me they just went for a bigger
name being Hollywood lead and I'm happy
to pass it on to Ralph the next version
of Voldemort that we see on screen is in
the Chamber of Secrets
where we see Christian Coulson playing a
16 year old Tom Riddle Coulson is a
British actor who was born in Manchester
England and had a fair bit of acting
experience under his belt before taking
on the role unlike Bremer Coulson had
the honour of having more of a physical
presence on screen complete with his own
body
Coulson played the role of Voldemort in
the past a younger version of himself
and so for this reason it was necessary
that they bring in another actor Bremer
was simply too old to play the role of
young Tom Riddle and so Coulson was cast
Coulson was 23 himself but was
convincing enough
the next version of Voldemort that we
see on screen it belongs to none other
than Ralph Fiennes who assumes the role
the present timeline Voldemort that we
all know and love interestingly enough
Fiennes was actually reluctant to take
on the role at first and said the
following in an interview the truth is I
was actually ignorant about the films in
the books I was approached by the
production Mike Newell was directing the
film that they wanted me to be it the
first time Voldemort was going to appear
physically out of ignorance I just sort
of thought this isn't for me quite
stupidly I resisted I was hesitant
I think the clincher was that my sister
Martha who has three children who were
then probably about 12 10 and 8 she said
what do you mean you've got to do it so
then I rewound by thinking fortunately
for all of us fine sister Martha knocked
some sense into him his performance of
Voldemort from the half-blood Prince
onward was spectacular and it's obvious
that he really put his heart and soul
into the role he made it entirely his
own and for good reason finds is the
definitive image of Voldemort in most
fans Minds next up came hero finds
Tiffin who played the 11-year old
version of Voldemort at walls orphanage
in London the orphanage where he was
left by his mother in rope called Tiffin
was an important part of the half-blood
Prince film adaptation as he gave us all
a glimpse of what the Dark Lord was like
as a child finds Tiffin as you might be
able to guess by the name is related to
actor Ralph Fiennes
he's his nephew Tiffin does an
exceptional job at portraying the young
wizard and nails the creepy but innocent
representation of Voldemort the
filmmakers were going for this was a boy
who knew that he was different but
didn't yet know what he was and what he
was destined to be at the same time as
Tiffin Frank Delaney was cast in the
role of Voldemort or at least a young
Tom middle Delaney was an integral part
of the film as he was the representative
for riddles character in the flashbacks
of him at age 16 by the time the half
butt prints came out Coulson would have
been just a little bit too old to play a
sixteen-year-old again which is why I
expect they cast Delaney
while Delaney was good I do
think that Coulson was a bit better
Coulson was more dynamic and that he was
able to more convincingly play both
sides of Voldemort's character he could
convincingly portray the good nature of
Voldemort while the teachers were around
but also had no difficulty playing the
more evil side of him Delaney was just
sort of a bit creepy all of the time and
that concludes the list of the five
actors that played Voldemort the present
timeline Voldemort was showcased by
Bremer and they defines the
sixteen-year-old Voldemort was showcased
by Coulson and later Delaney and the
eleven-year-old Voldemort was showcased
by Tiffin and that's it for this video
let me know who your favorites were and
why also what do you guys think of the
new background music until next time
you're a wizard Harry
you